es war ein bestialischer mord eine
grausame tat die eine ganze region tief
verstört hat der tatort ein alter nazi
bunker abgelegen im wald
[Musik]
und wir kommen zu unserem nächsten fall
der spielt ja eine gute stunde nördlich
von berlin in einem dichten waldstück
bei oranienburg dort liegt nämlich der
tatort eines grausamen mordes und dieser
tatort er ist ein alter bunker im schutz
der bäume hatten die nazis dort eine ss
funkstation eingerichtet und heute sind
die trümmer dieses bunker ist ein
beliebtes ziel für lost places
abenteurer für wanderer die eben dorthin
gehen das internet dass es voll mit
guten tipps wie man heute am besten noch
in diesem bunker und in diese trümmer
hinein klettert und genau das machen im
vergangenen sommer zwei junge männer sie
steigen also durch das loch in diesem
bunker und den decken dann dort eine
frauenleiche matthias lukaschewitsch
jörg völkerling und stefan sander
erzählen die ganze geschichte
das opfer ist eine junge frau aus
oranienburg als sehr zuverlässig galt
und von daher war auch dieses
verschwinden seit dem donnerstag seit
dem 15 sehr ungewöhnlich so zeugen die
die frau dort schon haben waren wir
diesen pokerface places so ein bisschen
dick
es war ein bestialischer mord eine
grausame tat die eine ganze region tief
verstört hat der tatort ein alter nazi
bunker abgelegen im wald das opfer
bianca eine junge mutter aus oranienburg
der angeklagte hotel ein
langzeitarbeitsloser
seit mittwoch wird ihm der prozess
gemacht im gerichtssaal gibt er einblick
in seine düstere gedankenwelt und
spricht diese unheimlichen setzte
seit 15 jahren folgt mit der sensenmann
er ist immer da ich sehe sein gesicht
nicht er trägt eine schwarze kapuze
gesicht arme und beine sind von einer
kutte bedeckt
wer ist dieser mann hat der bianca
ermordet im alten nazi bunker kurz vor
dem liebesakt achtung fahndung erzählt
die ganze geschichte von der fahndung
bis zur festnahme
[Musik]
bianca und kurt l lernen sich im märz
2020 kennen die beiden leben in
oranienburg doch ihre beziehung wird
schon bald zur on off beziehung immer
wieder gibt es streit und immer wieder
kehrt bianca zu ihrem kurz zurück laut
ermittlern ist sie ihm hörig soll alles
für ihn getan haben auch sexuell und
selbst wenn es weh tat wir treffen
biancas mutter yvonne erstmals spricht
sie über ihre tochter und ihr verhältnis
zu hotel
schon stutzig geworden wo er im zeit
gesagt hat
er hat zwei seiten
hat eine gute seite er hat aber auch nur
schlechte seite und der katze aus dem
sack ich muss ständig rechte seite nicht
kennen
dann meine tochter gut der rest ist mir
egal
aber dann kam mir ein teil der bürger
machen also könnten jedoch
versteckt im wald liegt der alte nazi
bunker die funkstation einer ss
nachrichten einheit deckname karas im
norden der reichshauptstadt hatten die
nationalsozialisten damals bauten des
schreckens und des terrors errichtet und
das kz sachsenhausen das angrenzende ss
truppen lager ganz in der nähe das
städtchen oranienburg das letzte
lebenszeichen von bianca gab es hier am
bahnhof in oranienburg am vergangenen
donnerstag um 13 uhr war sie hier mit
einer freundin verabredet die später
auch den such aufruf nach ihr startete
in einer fahrradabstellanlage etwa 50
meter von ihr hatte bianca regelmäßig
ihr damenfahrrad abgestellt eine
überwachungskamera fängt die szene am 15
juli 1 bianca schiebt ihr fahrrad sie
hat ihre rosa vieler handtasche dabei
trägt ein weißes tanktop auf dem berlin
kopenhagen radweg fährt bianca ist ein
stück dann biegt sie ab in den wald die
ermittler glauben irgendwo hier trifft
sie kurt l gemeinsam sollen die beiden
zum nazi bunker gelaufen und in ein
kleines loch in die beton festung
eingestiegen sein laut
staatsanwaltschaft rauchen und trinken
die beiden dann zieht sich bianca aus
plötzlich so die ermittler sticht kurth
l mit einem geschärften 10 cm
stechbeitel auf sie ein sieben mal in
hals rücken und nacken
die wird um ihr leben wird sie geschrien
haben auf jeden fall also war das stimmt
mich so leicht weil sie hat ja ihr kind
immer ihr liebt
und jetzt steht der kleine im ton und
mama da und das ist schon hart
an diesem tag soll bianca eigentlich zu
einer teambesprechung bei ihrem chef
erscheinen doch sie kommt nicht auch ihr
sohn gianluca wartet um 16 uhr an der
kita vergeblich auf seine mama als
bianca am donnerstag ihren sohn nicht
von der kita abholte machten sich ihre
freunde und ihre familie sorgen sie
starteten sofort eine suchaktion ihre
großmutter meldete bianca am freitag um
12 50 bei der polizei als vermisst
die polizei beginnt mit den ermittlungen
dann die schreckliche gewissheit hier am
alten nazi bunker karo ass etwa 15
fahrminuten von biancas wohnungen in
oranienburg entfernt fanden zwei männer
am montagabend die leiche der
26-jährigen mantrailer hunde der polizei
hatten bei der suche zuvor nicht
angeschlagen am tatort läuft die
spurensicherung auf hochtouren vor ort
zeugen blumen kerzen und ein
beschrifteter pulli von großer trauer
hallo mama ich vermisse dich so sehr in
liebe dein sohn gianluca ist darauf zu
lesen wir haben mit einer jungen
helferinnen gesprochen die bei der
bergung der leiche am montagabend dabei
war den tatort mit ausgeleuchtet hat und
die dann im angesicht der leiche
feststellen musste dass es sich um eine
schulfreundin von ihr handelt die sie
selbst seit der sechsten klasse kannte
tagelangen scheint das heißt kämen die
ermittler in dem fall nicht weiter sie
wenden sich an die öffentlichkeit bitten
um hinweise
die polizei sucht dringend nach zeugen
die altenpflegehelferin muss offenbar
kurz bevor dem bunker von ihrem mörder
abgefangen worden sein also unsere
ermittler gehen immer noch davon aus und
wir natürlich ganz genau so dass dieser
fall geklärt wird wir werden alles daran
setzen egal wie viel tage jetzt auch
schon vergangen sind wir haben am
vergangenen freitag noch mal einen
zeugenaufruf rausgegeben mit der
beschreibung der frau auch mit bildern
der frau was sie zur tatzeit an hatte
und hoffen weiterhin darauf dass sich
auch weitere zeugen bei uns melden und
hinweise geben dafür werden wir sehr
dankbar dann der durchbruch es ist der
juli beamten der mordkommission nehmen
kurth l in seiner wohnung fest und
führen ihn in handschellen aus dem haus
kriminaltechniker interessieren sich
besonders für das fahrrad des
langzeitarbeitslosen millimeter für
millimeter werden der rahmen die
schaltung die bremsen die felgen
vermessen und fotografiert hotel kommt
in untersuchungshaft
er schweigt zu den vorwürfen
es ist eine gute nachricht einer der
dramatischsten kriminalfälle der woche
steht offenbar kurz vor der auflösung
hat die polizei die hat endlich einen
tatverdächtigen im fall bianca es
geschnappt in den wochen danach finden
die ermittler die wichtigsten
beweisstücke biancas fahrrad und ihre
handtasche in der nähe des nazi bunkers
das landgericht neuruppin am mittwoch
prozessauftakt gegen kurt l die tat
gesteht er nicht doch er spricht andere
gruselige setzte biancas freundin ist
erschüttert über die tat
als freunde also umarmung kisten und so
wir sehen und hören uns
[Musik]
dann haben sie gesehen
die us mutter hofft dass der mutmaßliche
mörder ihrer tochter nie wieder frei
kommt doch egal wie das urteil ausfällt
der schmerz wird bleiben man macht sich
gedanken wie ist der tod überhaupt
vonstatten
also es ist schwer damit umzugehen also
ich muss sagen in der weihnachtszeit zum
beispiel war sehr schlimm für mich also
konnte kein einziges foto von mir sehen
weil genau wusste wie sehen sie das ja
nicht
ich hab manchmal denn so das hat meine
mama auch muss ich die fotos umdrehen
[Musik]
unterdessen wird der prozess gegen hotel
fortgesetzt den mutmaßlichen mörder
droht lebenslange haft
natürlich werden wir diesen prozess
gegen code l weiter genau begleiten